i said that's the problem with
statistics is that they can play into
they're not framed just right they can
play into the
more fearful parts that's exactly what
you're doing adam
i've watched adam ruins everything in
the past sometimes
i agree but sometimes i very very much
disagree so let's take a look at his
episode on hospitals
i just need to be healthy just give you
everything
actually when it comes to medicine
getting everything could make you less
healthy
that is a hundred percent accurate
getting more care isn't necessarily
better
than getting less care not only can it
be a waste of money
but it can also lead to over-diagnosis
which means giving you a diagnosis
that had you not known about you live a
healthy normal life or
it can lead to further downstream
testing which then can carry their own
side effects
if i give you an unnecessary test to
check for prostate cancer
and then it says you may have prostate
cancer
gives you a false positive then you end
up getting a prostate cancer biopsy
which is an invasive procedure with a
needle down there and then as a result
of that you get an infection
and then we find out you didn't really
have prostate cancer you'd be pretty mad
at me right i know the hospital is
expensive but it is worth it if i get
the best treatment
no it isn't american healthcare is not
the best in the world but despite that
we spend more per person annually on
healthcare than
any other developed nation and a big
part of the reason for that
is that american hospitals overcharge
patients massively
i've seen this show before and i really
like how he takes apart
the concept and makes it easy to
understand relatable and also
it's very data driven however when you
take such a complicated topic like
healthcare
and you try and water it down to a
single statement you're often going to
be misleading people
america's healthcare system is not the
best in the world and it's because
hospitals are overcharging you
that's a drastic drastic
oversimplification do hospitals
overcharge
yes the reasons they overcharge are very
important to discuss
because if you just allow the regular
person to hear that
they think hospitals are just trying to
get rich off people getting sick
it's more complex than that the problem
starts with something called
the charge master the charge master is a
secret document full of insane prices
that hospitals use to charge us whatever
they want
seven dollars for single alcohol swab
that's ridiculous
and true well i only pay my premium
if they want to rip off my insurance
company with their fake prices what do i
care
insurance companies have been paying
more and more out of pocket because the
hospitals have been inflating their
prices
the way insurance companies have dealt
with this is they try and keep your
premiums from rising too much so you
don't notice that you're paying more
but what they do is they make your
deductible much higher which means that
before your insurance even kicks in
you have to pay higher amounts of money
don't have insurance
you actually get charged these fake
prices
let's see heart x-rays that'll be
33 000. this part is is interestingly
true if you don't have insurance and you
have to pay out of pocket
you're going to be paying insane prices
a lot of hospitals
because i don't want to make hospitals
to sound like totally evil corporations
they have charity care programs like my
hospital where they actually
subsidize your care and if you fall
below the poverty line you can get care
extremely low cost or even free of
charge this is why i say that it's such
a dense and complicated topic just
narrowing down saying hospitals are evil
not exactly the case they're not just
upping the prices for their own good
every hospital has its own charge master
a treatment that costs seven
thousand at one hospital could cost a
hundred grand down the road and you
can't comparison
shop when you're dying so this is 100
true when i talk about the cost of
health care or even the cost of drug
prices like insulin
i have to make the statement that you
can't treat health care
like you do any other commodity if a toy
is too expensive and people refuse to
pay that cost
the cost of that toy is going to go down
or the toy is going to go off the market
however if insulin is too expensive and
you need insulin to live
whatever cost is set for you you're
going to pay it even if it means going
bankrupt in the process
because you need that insulin to live
and the thing that really bothers me
there's no transparency here you don't
know what pharmaceutical companies are
charging you don't know what
uh pbms which are pharmacy benefit
managers are making off medications
without the transparency
you can't make an educated consumer
decision for example if you look at an
industry where
the prices are transparent like let's
say plastic surgery if you go to one
office they'll tell you what it costs to
get a procedure done then you can go to
another office and they tell you what
the procedure is
the reason they do that is because you
pay cash so they're forced to tell you
but when you go through insurance
they're not necessarily forced to tell
you
therefore it becomes very cloudy and you
can't make a good decision
this is why prices in the plastic
surgery industry
are much better regulated and are much
more transparent
because they're forced to be because
it's consumer driven
in healthcare because you don't have a
choice and because it's going to the
insurance company and there's no
transparency
the whole system falls apart how can i
stop it what do i do
honestly nothing we need to go to the
hospital so they have no incentive to
change how they do business
and politicians have spent decades
arguing over how to pay the bill
instead of asking why the bill is so
high hospitals need to exist and they
also need to turn a profit in order to
exist if hospitals just start handing
out free care or not following up on the
bills
or taking lower premiums from insurance
companies they're going to go out of
business and we're going to have no
place to get health care
so villainizing the hospital system is
not ideal
working the entire system and evaluating
the system as a whole and saying the
system is
failing us that's more of the big
picture that we need to be looking at
saying that politicians have been
arguing and how to pay the bill
instead of actually fixing the problem
is a hundred percent accurate
it's so much easier as a politician to
get people behind you
to say we should just pay all your bills
then actually figuring out why the bills
are so high
and getting into the nitty-gritty
details of them all that's it
i'll get a mammogram it will cure my
cold but it will tell me i don't have
cancer so at least i will have beaten
one disease today
i don't understand i thought every woman
needed screenings like
constantly yeah that's what doctors and
advocacy groups have told us for decades
in the 80s the american cancer society
even ran an ad that said
if you haven't had a mammogram you need
more than your breasts
examined he wants to make it a very
visceral primitive reaction
to what happened in the 80s but in the
80s the research that we had at the time
the best research that we had at the
time
showed that by getting mammograms we can
extend life and save lives and prevent
people from developing worse breast
cancer
now because we did that research and we
over screened people unfortunately part
of the course when you're doing
preliminary research
we've realized that we should push the
start date of when you should be getting
your mammograms
to a little bit later in life unless you
fall into a very specific set of
uh circumstances like if you have a
specific gene mutation or family history
that sort of thing
based on randomized clinical trials if
you took 10 000 women in their 40s
here's how many might die of breast
cancer if they didn't get any mammograms
for
a decade and here's how many of those
same women might die if they did get
those mammogram screenings
take off your blindfold they both look
the same
exactly very oversimplified with how
he's presenting the data this research
that he's talking about is about people
that died in that decade
not taking into consideration how that
breast cancer affected them in their
quality of life
in the decades moving forward but that
is the reason in general why we
moved our recommendations to getting
screenings later in life
and getting them less frequently now
that doesn't mean you shouldn't get
mammograms you absolutely should get
mammograms
it's just about when you get them and
that's why i recommend
everyone at home to go and talk to their
doctor about
what's right for them mammograms find
cancer
i have many pamphlets that say that well
they definitely find cancer
but not all cancer is the same there's
the kind of cancer you were thinking of
the kind you hoped to catch early yeah
that one hasn't reached the finish line
yet
a mammogram could stop it in time it
might
[Music]
the problem is mammograms can't tell the
difference between these types of cancer
that's true but that's why when you get
a mammogram we don't just do a mammogram
and then say oh well you either have
cancer you don't
we follow that up with a biopsy which
then tells us which type of cancer it is
and that's how we guide our treatment so
again an oversimplification
that can confuse the average person
there's a chance the x-ray will show
something suspicious when the woman
doesn't even have cancer
that's called a false positive this
happens to about 1 out of 10 women and
it can be very stressful
and the more often you get mammograms
the more likely you are to get a false
positive i try and watch this from
an average person perspective and when i
do that
what i feel is mammograms are useless
and can actually hurt me
that's not the message we want to send
to people the message we want to send to
people is
go talk to your doctor and if you need a
mammogram your doctor recommends them
it's a good thing
now challenge them and ask them why or
should you wait
and ask good questions but putting the
information out to the general public
like this that doesn't have a lot of
scientific knowledge
you can really confuse people and
actually encourage them to not get
screened
most people will do anything to skip out
on one of these cancer screenings
and to have a show like this tell them
that it's not the greatest
test in the world a woman who's 55 will
watch this
and who already has a predisposition to
not want to get a screening will watch
this and say i'm just not going to get
it
and that's not what we want to happen if
you do feel a lump or an abnormality
please go see your doctor
and if they recommend a mammogram get
one at that time exactly that's good
advice
but the problem is all that advice comes
after you just scared the bejesus out of
people who
might actually need mammograms so i'm
not a fan
of the way that this mammogram special
was presented even though
factually accurate there is some good
news our treatment of breast cancer is
so much better than it used to be
the mortality has dropped significantly
the reason why
our treatment is so much better is
because we
found so many of these cancers early
because of mammograms
they spent all this time knocking
mammograms at least give credit to
mammograms
for causing breast cancer mortality
rates to drop one in eight
in a lifetime and it's of a diagnosis
not of death
i see that's the problem with statistics
is that they can play into they're not
framed just right they can play into the
more fearful parts that's exactly what
you're doing adam i mean
yes we don't say one in eight women will
die from breast cancer we say they'll
develop it
so if you're being clear with the
statistic that you're giving a patient
or a person can make their own decision
on how they feel about that statistic
adam has great intentions and you want
to present information he wants it to be
controversial and edgy and disruptive
that's good but unless you've had
clinical experience
where you understand how patients
normally come in you won't be able to
tailor that information to do something
meaningful
like if i was to make this show i would
make it with the presumption
and the knowledge that patients come in
generally afraid of mammograms
and i would be able to tailor the show
with that in mind
and maybe won't be as funny or edgy or
disruptive
but at least it'll be meaningful because
that's the idea of making quality health
content it's to not only entertain
but to somehow give a piece of education
that's going to make a lasting impact
and that's why we have to always measure
the intentions and then see if the
outcomes match the intentions
because i bet if i show this to 100
women who are let's say
at the age let's say 50 years old to get
a mammogram and i let them watch this
really quickly and ask them what they
feel about mammograms after
i guarantee you the majority of them
will be more turned off on mammograms
even though they shouldn't be
because of the show and that's a
negative outcome did you see where dr
mike ruins detoxies
click here and stay happy and healthy